oh sorry about tonight's results what
what what hold on let me let me pick my
pride up off the floor
no what will you learn from your dancing
with the stars experience
oh it was fun i had a blast man you know
i got to meet some great people got a
new friend in emma you know it was fun
and this show um as a new artist in
country music this show really gave me a
platform
and really introduced you know new
people to my music and i've seen the
results already from you know social
media to digital streaming to even
concert tickets
and i'm gonna take away a lot because
it's
been one of my most favorite easily
seasons um despite the outcome but even
with that outcome because i mean weekly
it's not like we we miss out on one week
so it doesn't feel i don't know why i'm
doing this you just gave it to me and
i'm just like playing with it sorry it's
the type of person that you are why do
you do that
um
yeah i just
i it's hard to be it's hard to be said
oh thank you it's hard to be sad when we
have this overwhelming feeling of like
we got to be part of something so so
special we're so grateful and i feel
enriched to have in my life very cliche
thing to say but i kind of feel positive
about the future because of some of the
things that i have seen and witnessed
jimmy do that i want to i want to
implement in my own life i don't know i
feel i feel okay about everything it's
meant to be and we're both happy
positive people oh yeah
so it's all good
emma how did you feel about the hashtag
little emma that tyra mentioned
apparently uh apparently emma is
trending on um twitter yeah the last two
weeks i tried it last time but i clicked
on it last time and it was and it was
emma stone
no it wasn't no you really it was i
don't well no i sort of heard that
tweet but um but yeah it was so cute and
he's he's the best so like little emma
that's really cute
emma there was a name for jimmy
huh
emma do you have a nickname for jimmy
um like uh you know what in dance i used
to say boy oy boy
boy goes here
it's just a dance term isn't that weird
like i mean yeah you're british
yeah you see he's always doing to me but
uh in dancing more phrases what she says
more he goes here it's more her phrases
less uh
yeah a name less yeah there's a lot of
phrases you say but now it's more
phrases yeah yeah yeah
emma i can think of one season in
particular where you advance forward and
sasha was voted off and tonight we've
seen
i think i made you cry
now we've seen the reverse and can you
talk about
how how you feel about sasha moving
forward in his comeback this week i mean
of course i feel ecstatic that sasha and
suny are moving forward it was a
fantastic dance tonight and um and i
really feel like they've had a rise
because it wasn't so long ago it was
they weren't getting tense and um suny
was frustrated and um and they had to
work harder and now they've got to a
place where they're they're getting
those tens they got the highest score
they could possibly do tonight and i'm
so proud of them both like they they're
such sasha's a great partner for suny
and suny like really shone today she did
a thing today oh yeah i'm ecstatic
they're moving forward
are you going to continue to dance
no no
i'm done dancing bro like will i be back
to the show to hang out support my
friends and come back next season you
know like one episode for sure and hang
out for sure i love being in the
ballroom but i'm just glad i don't have
to dance
anymore
i've done it but i'm taking so much
stuff i've learned from her some of the
little moves and like throwing them in
the show but my main thing man i just
want everybody to steal the show to have
fun and don't have survivors remorse
that's the worst thing you know when
people get upset because some people get
sent home i want people still here to
still enjoy it yeah still have fun
you're still on an incredible journey
and if you're still in you got a chance
to win so enjoy it and have a good time
yeah yeah awesome were you surprised
that all that the judges decided to save
melora no not at all i mean laura's
incredible is incredible how to save my
lord
what kind of question is that soon i saw
going against me laura i started packing
my stuff i was already knew what time it
was and my laura is great you know
because i turned to each other
it was like you know what time it is
yeah i felt i felt i felt like the miz
last week when he was the bible verse
jojo i knew what was happening yeah
cause my laura's great she's having fun
um you know every week i expect to go
home i just wanted to make it till
disney week after week four i was good i
could have left it you know what i mean
how long i made the disney week that was
my main goal
but uh it's been fun been a great
experience and uh i'm looking forward to
seeing you going win
any chance you would join a future
dancing with the stars tour
as a host and of course no as
the host uh you only danced like two
dancers well how about none and i just
host and tell jokes no
people want to see you dance they don't
yes they do they did they voted for me
oh a lot of people voted
a lot of people voted oh yeah i know it
was fun but yeah i i am going to go to
some dancing stars tours i would
definitely love to go see it be involved
in some way maybe do one little trick
like a span
but uh listen i didn't dance before this
show i enjoyed my time here i hate
dancing
i'm good
well how about as a future performer
with people dancing around you now i
would do that okay i would perform i
would sing come out play the piano with
dancers on the piano and sparkle and
glitters everywhere yeah that's a good
one little chickens and cows everywhere
you know call it country night on the
ballroom floor
everybody chew on tobacco
good now